so the premiere of keeping up with
kardashians is tonight
um we see in a trailer that chris says
she gets a call from you so are we gonna
see you in this final season and how
much will we see you
uh put it this way uh i am in the final
season
um yes i make my return
um and so uh yeah
i i over the many over ten years i did
the show
i really enjoyed doing the show yeah um
really brought my family very close
together
we went through a lot together i think i
had probably some of the best
conversations with my kids on camera
it was a great experience great
experience and that's the only thing i
see the end of the show
is it's kind of you know sad but all my
kids
every one of them you know even not just
the ones on the show
but all my other children that i have i
couldn't be more proud
they've all been very successful you
know i see especially kendall and kylie
the ones on the show uh we're very close
we talk
all the time i go to kylie's house
for dinner at her house you know once a
week once every two weeks
sit down talk about life talk about
what's going on in their lives and this
and that so
and i cherish those moments right
the one thing that i really love too
about all of you all
the ups and downs the goods and bad and
we we saw you and kimberly have
you know a really nice um relationship
through you know most of of the seasons
and so i wonder how are you guys
rallying around her now
because of course she's going through a
difficult time in her life
with her divorce yeah well one thing i
have learned
in being involved with this family
is let them speak for themselves
i i love kim i i love kanye
i mean we really had a good relationship
and i hope the best for both of them
but to find out what's going on you're
gonna have to talk to them
i have to say listen i know that people
said how did you not know that it was
caitlyn jenny
said that to me caitlin i did not know
that it was you i was thinking when it
was like track and famous family i was
going to the logic
like oh maybe the joyner kirsty family
maybe
i totally was not putting those clues
together so what was that like number
one
when you took that mask off and everyone
finally said
it was you first of all uh
i was so happy that nobody voted for me
and i was the first one off i mean
it was that job is tough yeah i mean i
literally worked for months it's a tough
show to do
it's out of my element you know i was
known for
running fast and jumping over things and
throwing things you know
um and but it was
a big challenge i was happy that
i was the first to go i wish you i
wouldn't like to go on one more
just because my next song was the
temptations
oh which one were you i know you wanna
leave
me and i was ready to go with that one
yeah hey yeah i like getting out of your
element and taking risks
well isn't that kind of the advice you
always give your kids is like don't
limit yourself
take risks take chances yeah
this is the one line i always used to
get my kids
i used to tell them the ability to grow
is directly related to the amount of
insecurity
you can take in your life you have to
work in those
insecure areas i remember when kimberly
came downstairs uh she was 16
17 18 somewhere in there she came
downstairs
she goes oh my god i couldn't sleep last
night i was so nervous
and i said why she goes i have to do it
on camera today
where i'm actually talking to the camera
and she had never done that before
and i gave her that line and um
i said this is a growing experience for
you once you do it you're gonna do fine
that'll be your new norm so yeah taking
risks
um the good news is about this show
um when you talk about taking risks um
it proved that i'll probably never do it
again
you're like i got my phil i did my one
time
and i did it one time okay
i i crossed that bridge um and i'm
moving off
yes jenny knew it was you ken also
guessed but then he took it back were
you kind of inside saying oh
man that you know they they knew it was
me
um no i was very actually i was very
happy
i said um you know what was fun
is uh my son brandon um
he's in the music business and so when i
was gonna do this
i called him up i said brandon i need
some help you know this is not my field
it's your field
so i would go down to a studio and put
the headsets on and work on it and work
on the timing
i love it yeah yeah it's great and
brandon in my ear
was so was brandon the only one of your
kids you told you have to realize
that my fan points are professionals at
keeping
secrets yeah because the secrecy behind
that show
um is unbelievable i mean they take it
so seriously
i mean you can't even walk around
without a like this face covering on you
um they won't let anybody talk to you
they have a a sweatshirt that you are
wearing says don't talk to me
the phoenix represents a rebirth so was
that
why you know you you chose it i mean
what did this symbolize for you because
everybody that i talk to that does
these shows they also say they feel a
freedom about it because they are behind
the mask because they can just kind of
let it all go and no one really knows
who they are i noticed from one of the
photography sessions we were taking
pictures
and i'm inside this mask and i'm going
oh you know look
i said wait a second they can't even see
me in here why am i even
smiling and i have to admit i think
mine was the best costume out there